there's little safe water in Syrian
refugee camps like this one it was where
the first cases of Cholera were detected
in Lebanon earlier this month
it's believed to have been transmitted
by contaminated water or food from
neighboring Syria the lack of Sanitation
makes crowded camps high-risk areas
we really have a problem with the water
the water they give us is dirty we drink
it and cook with it too
come on
cases are no longer confined to camps
bordering Syria but they've since spread
to poor areas where drinking water is
widely polluted and at times mixed with
waste water
Lebanese officials are warning that it
will be a challenge to contain the
disease in a country in the midst of an
economic crisis with limited resources
and bad infrastructure the disease is
according to the United Nations evolving
alarmingly disease is never respects any
any borders so it is very critical to
take action now unicefil is on the
ground with Partners we are working very
closely with who and other partners here
we are doing our level best to ensure
children receive clean water we are
chlorinating water in in the most
affected areas we are providing water
through water Trucking we are engaging
with communities sharing information on
how to stay safe and how to keep your
children safe
it may be too early to speak about an
epidemic in Lebanon but healthcare
workers say the threat is there and here
in the north officials say nearly all
the water sources are polluted
the cholera outbreak in Lebanon and
Syria is not slowing humanitarian groups
are warning the disease could spread
throughout the Middle East affecting
millions of people but they too have
been criticized for not having a firm
and coordinated response
in Syria there have already been dozens
of deaths nearly fifteen thousand
suspected cases and according to the
World Health Organization cholera has
reached 14 of the 15 governorates
years of war have severely damaged the
water infrastructure as well as the
health sector
our health system is already weak as a
result of the war and the shortage of
resources so an outbreak of any disease
will lead to the collapse of the entire
Health System
officials say they are working with
International organizations to ensure
the country can respond to a public
health emergency but in countries where
few can afford clean and bottled water
it may be hard to control
Northern Lebanon